La volta al món a peu, dia 260, són les 7 i 20, 7 i mitja de la tarda i avui camino sense motxilla.
Però no una passejada, no, avui avanço a la ruta.
A veure, us ho explico, avui és diumenge, dia 16 d'agost i avui havia de tornar a caminar.
Va bé, ha passat dues nits aquí, ahir vaig estar descansant, hello, i avui havia de tornar a caminar.
Però no ho he fet. Avui el que he fet, em despisten els nens, avui el que he fet ha sigut agafar i dir-los, mira, em queda una nit més.
Per què? Estava molt cansat? No, perquè estic malalt.
Us ho explico, des de fa més de quatre dies, més de 90 i escaig hores, que són quatre dies,
estic malalt de la panxa. No us havia dit, això ha sigut des del dia del túnel de la mort cap endavant.
No us havia dit perquè pensàveu que seria una cosa que es solucionaria ràpid, però no, no, no, no.
El que tinc és, crec, el que diuen la diarrea del viatger. Potser no és això, però, bueno, pel que sembla és això,
que és, bueno, menges algun malestat o el que sigui, tens com un virus a la panxa i tal.
El que no és molt normal que duri tant de temps.
Tants dies es veu. Llavors, quines són les conseqüències d'això?
Doncs que cada poc, tipus cada hora, cada dues hores de mitja, he d'anar al lavabo.
I quan vaig al lavabo, doncs, vaig tou, vaig molt líquid, molt líquid.
I, bueno, doncs aquells últims dies que estava caminant, doncs sí, havia d'anar a parar a un lavabo
de la carretera, amagat una mica, i feia el que havia de fer.
I, bueno, just abans de venir, és molesta, l'estómac fa mal, però just quan ja ho fas, doncs ja se't passa
i pots continuar tranquil·lament. Però, clar, és molest. A més, el perdre tant de líquid,
diuen que això pot ser dolent perquè pots deshidratar-te, especialment amb aquestes claus que fa, no?
Pot ser una mica perillós.
Però, perillós, perillós, no sé.
Bueno, el tema, que no m'he recuperat, m'he quedat un dia més, però és que avui tampoc m'estic recuperant.
Què passa? Hauria d'haver anat al metge, no?
Doncs, clar, és que anar al metge va una cosa tan poc important, perquè si jo no estigués de viatge,
estigués, doncs, visqués aquí, doncs mira, esperes que es passi.
I ja està, saps? Però, bueno, clar, el fet d'estar de viatge, doncs, em molesta perquè jo no necessito continuar, no?
Però jo què sé, el fet de durar tant, potser hauria d'anar al metge, sí.
Sí, encara no ho he decidit. Potser demà al matí, si estic encara així, que és el més probable,
perquè no sembla que marxi, doncs, potser hauria d'avisar, segur, a escriure i anar al metge a primera hora
i seguir encara, que no sé si ajudaria gaire.
Avui he anat a la farmàcia, avui el vídeo serà això, eh, xapa?
Avui he anat a la farmàcia i he comprat diverses coses.
He comprat les salts d'aquestes, tipus, hello, electrolits per replenar els electrolits i els minerals que se'n van
quan passen aquestes coses.
I he comprat un medicament per aturar la diarrea, no me l'he pres.
No me l'he pres.
Només serà en cas que jo hagi de començar a caminar.
Però té certs efectes secundaris, perquè dius, tu, ostres, atures la diarrea, doncs, perfecte, no?, és el que necessites.
No, perquè llavors, clar, la infecció no pot sortir.
La infecció surt per baix.
Llavors, clar, si talles això, doncs, tal.
Bueno, els medicaments aquests duren 8 hores, llavors, 8-12 hores, llavors, quan s'acaba l'efecte,
pot tornar encara amb més força, saps?, perquè, clar,
ha estat allà incubant, no?
Bueno, veurem, suposo que...
Després m'he comprat iogurt, també, com per restablir la flora.
No sé, ja veuré que és qüestió de temps, que passi, però no sé.
Potser no és un virus, és una altra cosa, saps?, i s'ha de mirar d'una altra manera.
En fi, quan vosaltres veieu això, ja hauré sortit a caminar o ja hauré anat al mitjà, per tant, tranquils.
Total, que ja sabeu que jo tinc pressa per arribar a la frontera en Xina, perquè, si no, m'agafo el fred.
Llavors, estic a muntar-me, i, de fet, m'agafo el fred.
Estic amb una mica de fomo i he dit, mira, ara fa estona que no menja res,
perquè, normalment, això em ve després de menjar alguna cosa.
Ara fa estona que no menja res, acabes d'anar a l'abo dues vegades,
doncs ara és el moment perfecte per sortir.
Llavors, avui caminaré una estona, no ho sé, dues hores, deu quilòmetres, no ho sé.
He aprofitat ara que s'ha anat el sol, que no fa tanta calor, perquè, bueno,
el dia que vaig caminar no vaig gravar, el dia d'arribar a Duxambe,
que va ser el dia de més calor.
He voltat la volta al món, vull dir, va ser horrible la calor que feia,
era descomunal, o sigui, durant el dia, és brutal.
A mesura que m'allunyi de Duxambe serà una mica millor,
tampoc molt millor, farà calor igualment, però aquí Duxambe és brutal,
feia, no sé si estem a 40 graus de màxima.
És un forn de bojos, de bojos.
Llavors, bueno, ara que s'ha anat el sol, caminaré,
ja més o menys està il·luminada la ciutat, espero.
Llavors jo caminaré 10 quilòmetres a la meva ruta, o els que siguin,
i quan em cansi agafaré un taxi i tornaré a l'hotel,
i demà continuaré des d'aquí a punt, tornaré a agafar un taxi i continuaré des d'aquí a punt.
Home, Enric, això no és l'essència, és trampa, no?
No, la trampa no és, però sí que és veritat que si fes això cada dia,
doncs no seria la volta amb una peu.
Però, bueno, com és el primer cop que ho faig, doncs, bueno.
El matí, l'altre dia el que vaig entrevistar, això ho ha fet diverses vegades,
al desert, i també tenint en compte que hi té un conductor
pel desert que va i torna a hotels o quan li convé,
perquè a vegades no és practicable de campar.
Bueno, doncs res, a veure què tal.
I bé, doncs això és Duxambe, com veieu, doncs, bueno,
ciutat normaleta, depèn del barri.
Aquí és com, bueno, normal, cases baixes, tal.
Quan vas més cap al centre, que m'està apareixent aquests dies,
doncs, és un altre món, eh?
És una mica tipus teixquent, no tan guapo, però edificis molt alts,
molt lluminosos, molts leds, molt, molt bé, molt bé.
Però, bueno, és la capital i han posat diners aquí,
en aquests edificis del centre.
El Parlament, aquest monument que simbolitza el fundador de la nació,
que ja en parlarem, i, bueno, altres coses.
Què he estat fent aquests dies?
Doncs, mireu, m'he trobat amb aquests, els coneixeu?
On Travelling.
No he gravat vídeo, però he estat amb ells.
No he gravat vídeo perquè, clar, ells com que van bastant enredadits amb els vídeos i tal, doncs,
tampoc volia fer molt de spòilers del que han fet i del que deixarem de fer.
Ja ho veureu als seus vídeos del seu canal de YouTube, no?, del que faran.
Però sí, sí, ara estan per aquí, a Targikistan,
i l'únic que us diré és que ells venen d'on vaig jo ara,
jo ara faré tot el pamir, i ells venen d'allà.
I, bueno,
bueno,
serà difícil.
O sigui, jo, els últims dies, després del túnel de la mort, vaig pensar, buah, aquest país serà molt difícil,
i, bueno,
aquells dos,
la Noa i l'Òscar, m'han confirmat,
hi ha molt poca cosa, hi ha molt poques,
les botigues estan molt espaciades,
són, a les botigues, als pobles de,
i ciutats del pamir no hi ha res, o sigui,
i no és barat, a més,
o sigui, no és car, tampoc, però no és com altres llocs, que no és barat,
llavors, estic una mica atemorit,
i una mica, no diria desanimat, però estic,
no amb il·lusió, saps el que vull dir?
O sigui, tu, quan se'm presenten problemes,
perquè la volta amb una peu sempre és algun problema,
sempre algun repte,
país, gran, nou, el que sigui,
doncs t'ho pots vendre, t'ho pots prendre com amb, dir, bueno, va,
m'ho prenc amb actitud positiva,
llavors, estic amb actitud positiva,
o t'ho prens així com, va, tinc por, no sé què,
i jo ara mateix estic així, o sigui, no ens enganyarem,
no m'ho estic prenent amb actitud positiva,
s'ha de ser conscient de la veritat,
això canviarà, pot canviar, pot canviar,
esperem que canviï,
ja he assumit creure una de pols brutal,
i he assumit que potser no torno a anar a un lavabo de tassa fins,
d'aquí un mes.
I la calor, que és el que més em preocupa.
A veure com el porto.
A part d'això, doncs, he fet una mica
de turisme, he comprat un barret, ja us
l'ensenyaré demà, i he comprat una bandera,
no tan gran com aquesta, però similar,
i me la posaré a la motxilla
a veure si no se'm cau
ni se'm vola.
Una altra pregunta que m'he fet aquests dies és
com voldré que hagués pillat això?
He comprat una aigua amb gas.
Tentaré menjar, beure menys refrescs.
No crec que sigui això, però crec que
bec massa refrescs, beure més aigua amb gas.
Bueno, doncs,
hi ha molts llocs on no he pogut
haver agafat això, perquè
les condicions higièniques són les que són,
però hi ha un lloc en concret
que jo crec que és el culpable.
Us en recordeu el dia que vaig acampar davant de la glacera,
aquell lloc tan espectacular on vaig acampar?
On vaig veure l'art de Sant Martí
amb uns altres, hi havia
una altra gent allà, uns pastors.
Els pastors em van oferir plof.
Bueno, jo vaig
menjar del seu mateix plat, era un plat
gran de plof,
i ells menjaven amb les mans
i jo amb una cullera.
Té tota la pinta
que...
Té tota la pinta que jo
portava ja molt de temps
o li havia donat tot el dia el sol
o les seves mans estaven brutes,
el que sigui.
El que sigui, però té pinta.
Però podria ser l'aigua.
Jo he filtrat tota l'aigua que he begut
o l'he comprat embotellat el 90% de vegades.
Llavors...
Jo crec que no, però també podria ser.
Un altre motiu perquè volia caminar avui
uns 10 quilòmetres o així
és perquè enganxat a Duxambe
hi ha una altra ciutat.
Això m'han dit
la noia i l'Òscar, i també surt al mapa.
Llavors, clar, si jo demà
camino 30 quilòmetres o així, potser encara
no he sortit de la ciutat.
I potser no tinc lloc per anar a acampar. Llavors, si avui ja faig 10,
doncs mira, com a mínim ja...
Això que...
Això que he guanyat.
I, bueno,
diumenge són les
8 i 45.
És a dir, hauria estat
tot recollit a casa, tal, però clar...
No, no, està tot
molt viu, perquè clar, aquí pel dia
és molt difícil fer vida al carrer.
I estan totes les botigues obertes
diumenge de nit, la gent pel carrer
comprant, venent,
cantidad de cotxes també bèstia,
mireu aquí, nens, tal...
Igual més o menys que
us veguis tard.
Enric, si volies estar dues hores
caminant i dius que et ve això
cada hora, què fas?
No? Et podies estar aquí al mig de la ciutat
i... Doncs mira, he vingut a la
pensinera, ara que tenia ganes,
després d'una hora i pico,
i he anat al lavabo
i ja està.
Tampoc gastaré molta estona més,
potser dues hores
i mitja com a màxim, potser no tant.
Potser no tant. Segueixo.
Mare meva, suposo que no us veu res,
però estic a un barri, ara,
brut, amb aigua per aquí,
cases així, pisos
de tres plantes, bastant fets caldo,
no hi ha res de llum,
hi ha la llum de la carretera, però il·lumina molt poc,
hi ha poca gent,
i estava pensant,
això,
a un barri com aquest, a qualsevol lloc d'Europa,
et cagaries de por, no?
Diries, uau, aquí
em robaran,
o el millor que pot passar és que
em robin.
Doncs no, tu, aquí a Tajikistan
vaig tan tranquil, eh?
Tan tranquil.
Doncs ja està, 10 quilòmetres,
travesso el carrer
perquè el taxi li agafa anant cap a l'altra banda,
però sí, sí,
però res, 10 quilòmetres,
ja estan fets, són les 9 i pico.
Sol anar-me'n a la dormidora, jo,
10 i pico.
Veig que als Tajiks no, perquè és que hi ha camions,
hi ha construccions, hi ha gent pintant coses,
deu ser la millor hora per fer
treballs manuals, perquè no fa tanta calor.
Val, doncs avui 10 quilòmetres,
un refresc,
no he parlat amb ningú,
i m'he gastat,
demà, demà us diré com m'he gastat
tots aquests dies, perquè els hotels aquí
no són barats, eh? Hi ha pocs turistes i això es nota.
Bueno, un vídeo una mica random,
hagués pogut no fer-lo,
però crec que és millor fer-lo
que no fer-lo, no? Així us explico una mica
el que ha passat,
no us quedeu sense vídeo, que alguns sou molt ànsies,
és a dir, quan estic 3 dies sense posar vídeo
esteu nerviosos,
i bueno, doncs mira, així també us explico
aquesta part. Pel que sou nous,
normalment els vídeos són millors, no són així de cutres.
Demà tornem amb la sèrie.
Bona nit!